I'll tell you,
we still got it, Otis.
Oh, yeah.
Yes, we do.
- True that, Walden.
- Mm-hmm.
- All right.
- We here, ain't we?
Oh, yeah. Hey, we hittin' it
in business right now.
[both croak loudly]
[both sigh]
We out here, straight
hitting the bricks, as it were.
Hey, hey, I'm gonna
tell you right now,
I got a pocket full of nickels,
and I'm ready to get loose.
- All right!
- [laughs]
- Okay.
- Can I, uh...
get another round, please?
[hip-hop music playing]
- Here we go.
- Oh, yeah.
[both mumbling]
You guys like Drake?
- Drink?
- A drink?
We got--we got drinks.
- All sorted out on the...
- We got 'em, young buck.
Drink front there,
Tiny Tim.
Drake.
Like Drake, the rapper.
He's a musician.
Like, "Started from the bottom,
now we here."
Drake.
Drink?
You saying "drink."
You know a musician
called Drink?
Okay, you know what?
Never--never mind.
Uh, you guys are awesome.
♪
[both scoff]
- Drink.
- Awesome.
He over here talking
about Drake.
- "You guys are awesome."
- I don't know about no Drake.
I don't know nothing
about no Drake.
I'll tell you another thing,
I'm trying to watch
my calorie intake.
Ain't worried
about no Drink.
Concerned about
digesting my steak.
- Talk about Drake.
- Talking about Drake.
I'm having a hard enough time
staying awake.
I can't be concerning
myself with Drake.
You know.
Poured orange juice
on my corn flakes.
Yeah.
He talking about Drake.
Trying to talk about Drake.
I need five breaths
to blow out my birthday cake.
I ain't concerned
about no Drake.
- Drake.
- You want to be
concerned about Drake,
that's on your time, brother.
Shoot, man.
Lost my teeth in a lake.
I'm over here
like a 1930s cartoon
hitting my head
when I step on a rake.
[mimics slap]
Whoo!
[mimics birds flying]
I don't know no Drake.
Over here talking about Drake.
You concerned about Drake.
I'm gonna tell you
what I'm concerned about.
Making it to the john without
making a bathroom mistake.
My left eyeball
is a fake.
Sperm, my testicles
do not make.
I woke up this morning
and my booty hole ache.
- Drake. Drake.
I ain't give a shit
about no Drake.
You know all about Drake.
[speaking gibberish]
Drake.
[scoffs]
Oh, hey, now.
Look at them.
Look at these two
old-timers over here.
[both chuckling]
Now, take it easy
on them, Walden.
[both laughing]
I will, Otis.
I will, brother.
I will.
[both chuckling]
Hey!
Hello, gentlemen.
Y'all like Drake?
(man)
Drake?
Hell, yes.
"Started from the bottom,
now the whole team
fucking here."
Y'all like
Tyler, the Creator?
♪